well thank you for the opportunity
share a few thoughts at the
noon after a couple really fascinating
presentations about the way biodiversity
information can really more rapidly and
more extensively and form actual
conservation action so before I make any
remarks I just wanted to note that being
here in the school of Aldo Leopold that
very famous report written by his animal
ecology animal management wildlife
management Sun stalker which informed
the management of the national parks of
the United States for close to 50 years
had basically needed to be redone to
reflect some of the realities of the new
dynamics in nature from climate change
some of which we just saw on the screen
and so there is a brand new report at
called revisiting Leopold I think it's
actually quite good on bias because I
was on the committee of course but it's
only 23 pages little pages just like the
original report and its really very well
written not by the committee but
informed by the committee and I I
commend it to you as a way to help think
about how we manage all of the the
biology of our planet and such a time of
change so I wanted to sort of address
sort of two aspects of the title of this
symposium one is sort of the global
scale and the other being spatial
biodiversity science and so I sort of
come to to this having been through a
lot of
international meetings in the last two
or three years one of which of course
was Rio plus 20 and one has to state
very candidly the Rio plus 20 at least
from an intergovernmental point of view
was a really serious disappointment I
mean basically nothing was actually
committed to by the government's a trio
a much better picture if you looked
outside the actual convention center
itself and looked at what the private
sector was doing what civil society was
doing and what levels of government
below the national level like cities and
states and provinces were doing but
nonetheless if you add it all up and you
really look at the challenge squarely it
is just not at the scale that we need to
be acting and it it seems to me that
most of the international negotiations
seemed to be treating the issue of the
environment as though it's just sort of
yet another issue that they have to
negotiate about and I really I feel very
strongly that the focus on trying to
stop at two degrees of climate change is
actually seriously uninformed and
seriously misguided that is a world
without tropical coral reefs and one
twelfth of humanity depends on tropical
coral reefs for their well-being and I'm
not going to sit here and add to
building the case for why two degrees is
too much but I think we all collectively
need to be working on that building more
evidence and basically Preston
those who engage in these kinds of
discussions and agreements to face the
reality that the biology of our planet
is not going to be well served by
letting climate change go to two degrees
and then of course if we really want to
stop at two degrees global emissions
have to peek in 2016 so is it all over I
know it isn't all over especially if you
look at the significant portion of
excess carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
that actually comes from three centuries
of destruction and degradation of
ecosystems worldwide and there's
absolutely no reason why a good chunk of
that maybe 50 parts per million of co2
can't be brought out back out of the
atmosphere by taking on ecosystem
restoration at a planetary scale so
having made that point I just want to
add that in to the way we think about
spatial planning that we have to
actually think about managing our planet
as the linked biological and physical
system that it is and is literally half
a degree of potential global warming
that could be avoided by doing that so
all right as we think about all these
things that actually can play in a
positive way to some of the biodiversity
conservation we were considering in the
end the two earlier talks so on a more
hopeful note about international
negotiations the Convention on
Biological Diversity having spent in my
view almost too much time
on access and benefit sharing and bio
safety protocols is now I think in a
much more serious frame of mind both as
a set of governments and as a
secretariat so whereas in 2010 at the
10th conference of the parties in Nagoya
every single nation had to admit that it
had failed to meet the biodiversity
conservation goals that they had sat
they have a whole new set of targets set
about the same time and I Ichi and
they're just meeting this past week and
the week before in India to really
seriously consider how they're actually
going to make those targets the
Secretariat is now led by a Brazilian
Valley ods who's bound and determined
that he's going to make a huge
difference through the convention on
biological diversity and the big issue
is more than anything else is going to
be the necessary financial resources to
do it a hard thing to raise in a world
with the economic conditions that we
currently have but really cheap
inexpensive I in the overall scheme of
things so that's something to both keep
an eye on and look for ways that we all
can sort of promote so what thrills me
about this particular symposium is this
emphasis on a global scale taking on the
issue at the scale it deserves and there
Watson bits and pieces that are sort of
trending in this direction around the
world particularly in civil society
in academia and I just think we all need
to wake up every morning remembering
that the problem is as big as it is and
we should be pushing for as big a scale
response as society is capable of so
that's what I really wanted to say about
global scale of things let's just always
remember how big the problem is and wake
up every morning newly fired up to do
something about that so the other part
of what I wanted to talk about and I
probably won't use my whole a lot of
time is how important this spatial
biodiversity science really is because
what we if we are if we were to succeed
and minimizing the loss of Biological
Diversity on the planet at the same time
as we deal with the increasing human
numbers and resource needs that John
displayed in such a simple and
straightforward graphic we're going to
have to have serious integrated
development planning in large units of
landscape so I'm not going to talk about
the Amazon which I usually talk about it
needs that very much but I'm thinking
I'm thinking about the savanna regions
of Africa which are now down to about
thirty percent of their original extent
and all the glorious biodiversity of
African savannas that we all rejoice in
you know is down in many cases it close
to ten percent of its original
population levels and that's a continent
with rapidly growing population
rapidly growing needs in terms of food
and which is also being looked to buy
other parts of the world as a potential
future source of food and it is also a
place where they're all these mining and
other natural resource interests that
are coming in from the outside and you
get a picture that looks like on the map
we saw of deforestation and logging
roads in the Congo so I think we have to
take the knowledge we already have which
you can see is considerable and work
that in to development planning at large
regional scales so the other supposed
and the real needs of society get met
but in a way that has far fewer
downsides for Biological Diversity and
you know you can make the same case over
again for say the mekong river and the
dams that people are thinking of putting
on the mekong river which would have a
huge impact on freshwater biodiversity
would hit the the fisheries of Cambodia
and ultimately the rice basket of
Vietnam so all these things really need
to be put together in in regional
planning something that in the end may
create more opportunity than it
restricts we have to just simply we
define how we recognize opportunity and
have all these things be part of a
conversation between all these different
elements not the least of which are the
local communities so I think that is the
the challenge in front of us I don't
think I need to belabor it any further
just really applaud this symposium
combining both that global scale and the
need for spatial planning thank you very
much take time for a couple questions
before we recess
yes
pick up on your landscape scale planning
point there's and also the last speakers
talk about the sociological aspects
particularly you close I'm talking about
the importance of local opportunities so
that's an often the typical navigate
we're hearing the global land grabs
including green crabs biodiversity
hotspots and things like that what are
you seeing in terms of the best efforts
were the best example so people do not
right thinking about spatial scale
biodiversity well that's a really tough
question because I immediately think of
ones where it could be better so I think
if you take it down to a level of maybe
a state government that what's been
going on in the state of Amazonas in the
Amazon or in our a aqua is probably a
better example all of those things get
brought into the way it it is both
planned and engaged in and works an aqua
is a better example because there seems
to be more consistent political will
from a government administration to
government administration the history on
that in Amazonas is shorter and more
volatile so and maybe maybe it would be
interesting to go back and and look at
the example of Costa Rica once again
because a lot has changed over 30 or 40
years both in terms of forestry guth we
growth but also I think community
engagement as well
yes so we know biodiversity data are
knitting Walters tall and there's this
welcome development around the world of
sites coming to get an integrated
science to understand biodiversity
I geo sites besides us you're working
Amazonia you really wanted father's
getting site based my reversal settings
own i guess my question would be in
order to sort of bulk up my observation
is your validity really understand
what's happening serve it what can we do
better can ray those site networks bring
a comprehensive hold please now the
screen efforts to observe biodiversity
so i suppose we could think of a sort of
a green biodiversity peace corps right
you know part of part of what we just
simply have to deal with is being
content to act on the information we
have because you really are in the end
game in a number of ways and you know
the number of protected areas that will
be created after the next decade or so
will be pretty small which means it's
hugely important for us not only to be
focusing on that but focusing on the
larger landscape and i think we really
need to emphasize the importance of
integrating protected areas into a
larger landscape that has connections in
it so that species can move around you
know like the joshua trees or marching
out of Joshua Tree National Park and
then we have to sort of keep thinking
about it as a series of approximations
on successive refining of what we think
needs to be done to sort of the face of
both the terrestrial part of the planet
but also the marine
well let's thank Tom and the rest of the
speakers for this afternoon session